une crise épidémique qui a un impact
économique vous pouvez retrouver le
cette ut co2 nicolas d'andric abordera
cette thématique
la situation actuelle en train de bien
sûr des annulations dans le monde
sportif et culturel avec cette dernière
annonce du premier ministre edouard
philippe de limiter les rassemblements à
100 personnes ont fait le point avec
mélanie poquet journalistes de la
rédaction
alors à l'instant nous enregistrons
cette émission moyenne toutes les
situations ne sont pas encore connues il
ya encore des réunions qui sont en cours
mais ce que nous savons déjà c'est du
côté du monde du football il n'ya pas
que les professionnels qui sont touchés
tous les matches sont annulés
près de 350 rencontres sont concernés
pour les ive et on écoute jean pierre
meurillon il est le président du
district de football des îles et qu'on
appelle la planche combler les clubs sur
le fait que ça concerne non seulement
les zélés les les compétitions les
rassemblements etc mais aussi les
entraînements les activités des écoles
de football etc et que donc bah il faut
se conformer à ça puisque c'est ce sont
les instructions qui nous chantonnay
alors côté culture aussi on a des
annulations à noter et oui ils auront
tenté d'organiser leurs événements
jusqu'au bout mais après les annonces du
premier ministre ce midi interdisant les
manifestations regroupant plus de 100
personnes les organes les organisateurs
de la foire de châteaux ont dû se
résoudre à annuler leurs événements la
centième fois n'aura été présentes que
ce vendredi 13 mars et du côté de saint
quentin en yvelines vers la déception
elle est aussi du côté du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et rencontre
une cité aurait dû se tenir du 14 au 21
mars alors que les compagnies étaient
déjà arrivés les scènes installées les
représentations sont annulés certaines
sont reportés sur la saison de lille 21
2022 mais les équipes organisatrices
maintiennent les tables rondes dans un
format plutôt original écouter lionel
masse et à le directeur de la scène
nationale
elles seront en revanche organisé
empreinte j'en parlais à prendre encore
de tous les intervenants à huis clos
face on imite une émission de radio ou
au studio télé et diffusée soit pas sur
nos sur nos réseaux sociaux soit sur
notre site web
parce que je pense que la parole des 800
invités il y avait des invités après
intéressant prestigieux donc on avait
envie de garder ces paroles là il ya
quand même des événements qui se
maintiennent à l'heure actuelle et
menthe
le festival électro de versailles grand
parc est les ciné concerts et les
soirées dans les plus petites salles
sont maintenus puisqu'ils accueilleront
au moins 200 personnes sont pas contre
reporter le concert prequel au montant
c'est la grande soirée à londres
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
régulièrement sur la page facebook du
festival pour vous tenir au courant
merci mélanie pour ce point global
n'hésitez pas à donc à consulter les
sites internet des liens des lieux
d'accueil de vos sorties nous venons
d'apprendre par exemple la fermeture du
château de versailles
ce soir et jusqu'à nouvel ordre